بعد شهر فقط اللمسك يغير رايه ويحضر حسابا
يتعقب طائره الخاصه
والصديقان حكيمي و مبابي تواجهها في 90
دقيقه
وتصدر من الصوت و25 سؤال مع الشفع عمر
اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
البدايه مع نشره ال ماسك اليوميه وعنوانها
الحظر والكلام اليوم مو عن حضر حساب ترامب
ولا اي من الحسابات الثانيه المحظوره لا
الكلام اليوم عن حساب او حسابات جديده تم
حذرهم فقال الماسك او خلونا نقول تويتر
يعني بشكل عام حضروا حساب اسمه جت هذا
الحساب هو عباره ومحتوى عباره عن تعقب
للطائر الخاصه
الحساب مثل ما قلنا بيعتمد على بيانات
موجوده في المجال العام في الوصول لموقع
طائره ماسك في حظر هذا الحساب هو انه ماسك
ومن شهر بس كان كلامه غير الكلام وكان له
تغريده قايل فيها انه التزامه بحريه
التعبير بيمتد لعدم حضر حساب بيتحكم او
بيتعقب تحركات الخاصه رغم انه هذا الشيء
بيعتبر خطر على سلامته وكثير طبعا همم
يعني مع حجب حساب ماسك او لما نجمع ماسكه
عمل هذه الحركه قام راح وطلعوا له التغريد
القديمه حقته وعلقوا على التناقض اللي
صاير وماسك ما رد مباشره ولا بره مثلا
بوضوح سبب تغير رايه لكن راحوا عمل فرد
ماسك قال انه اي حساب بينشر معلومات عن
الموقع الحالي لاي شخص راح يتم حظر لانه
في اعتداء على سلامه الاخرين لكن لو احد
نشر معلومات عن موقع الشخص بعد فتره مو
بشكل مباشر وحالي فهذا اوكي وما في شيء
وبعدها نشر وقال انه في ملاحق مجنون امس
لاحق سياره فيها ابنه الصغير اكل معتقدا
انه ماسك جوه السياره وقال انه الشخص هذا
اعترض السياره ومنعها من الحركه ونط على
مقدمتها ونشر فيديو كمان لشخص وطلب من
اللي يتعرف عليه او على سيارته انه يساعد
في التعرف عليه
ماسك بعدها اكد انه في صدر اتخاذ
الاجراءات القانونيه ضد اللي لاحق سياره
ابنه وصاحب الحساب اللي كان بيتتبع طيارته
وكل من يعرض عائلته للخطر وبالعوده للحساب
اللي كان بينشر موقع طياره ماسك فالحساب
بط مثل ما قلنا وكان عليه نصف مليون متابع
تقريبا وبيديروا طالب جامعي اسمه جاكسون
عمره 20 سنه وهذا طالب عنده حساب يتتبع
طياره ماسك على مختلف اقل من الصوت الاخرى
وكمان عنده 30 حساب اخر على تويتر بديرهم
ومنهم حساب شخصي وكلهم تمرهم وهذه
الحسابات على فكره بتتبع سيارات اخرين مثل
الجيتس ماركه
صاحب الحساب واللي ما استوى عاده
بالملاحقه ايضا قال انه ماسك السن الماضي
يعرض عليها 5,000$ ويقفل الحساب
في حلقه امس ما قلنا لكم كمان مستجدات
قضيه البلوجر المصريه هدير عاطف المحبوس
على ذمه التحقيقات هي وتليقها واخته
وزوجها بتهمه النصب والاحتيال من بعد 16
بلاغ تقدموا للسلطات بانهم اخذوا منهم
فلوس للاستثمار وما اعطوهم ارباح ولا
ارجعوا اي فلوس او مكاسب في حلقه امس
نقلنا اعترافات طريق هدير اللي توافقت مع
روايه اهلها وهي انه هدير ما كانت تعرف
شيء عن النشاط ابدا وانها لمن عرفت طلبت
الطلاق وانفصلت بالفعل الجديد اللي نقلته
وسائل الاعلام المصريه هو اعترافات هدير
نفسها هدير نفذ تماما علمها بممارسه
الطريقه وقالت انها عرفت لما بدات توصلها
مسجات من ناس بتقول لها رجع فلوسنا وصار
يوصلها كثير كمان تهديدات وهنا واجهته
واتخانقت معه وطلبت الطلاق
وقالت لي النيابه انها قطعت كل علاقتها
بالتجاره هذه كمان اقرت لل بقى انه فعلا
حسابها البنكي كان بيستخدم وجلس بيك
وبيستخدموا زوجها وبينزل فيه فلوس بس كان
قايل لها ان هو مضطر يعمل كده لانه حسابه
محظور من كثر الايداع فيه طيب واكدت كمان
انه ما كانت تعرف انه بيتاجر في العملات
الرقميه المحظوره في مصر وقالت انه بلال
كان بيستغل شهرتها اشغلو وعلشان يعمل
ارتفاعات وهمم يوقع به ضحايا المحامي هذه
طلب من النيابه كمان السماح لهدير بارضاع
بنتها اللي عندها ثقه في القلب والنيابه
سمحت لها بدايه
ليله امس تاهل المنتخب الفرنسي للنهائي
كاس العالم بعد فوزه على منتخب المغرب
بهدفين مقابل الشيء منتخب المغرب الى من
اول البطوله بقدم مستوى مبهر امس ما كان
اقل ابهاره لكن هذه هي الرياضه يعني للاسف
فيها فايز وخسران ومن وقت ما خلصت
المباراه والتحيات والتهاني لمنتخب المغرب
على الظهور والاداء المشرف مينا من الصوت
والعناوين خاصه طبعا مع الانجاز التاريخ
اللي حققه لكن بعيدا كمان عن المنتخب كل
في تفصيله ثانيه متعلقه بالمباراه وشغله
من الصوت ومتداول بشكل كبير كمان والتفسير
اللي بتخص لاعب فرنسا كيليان مبابي وشلاعب
المغرب اشرف حكيمي كمان اللاعبين اللي كل
واحد منهم يعني من اهم نجوم منتخب بلده
لكن همم يعني ممكن يقول ان هم الاهم صراحه
يعني كمان لكنهم كانوا خصمين همم مع انهم
في الحقيقه هم ايلين في نادي باريس سان
جيرمان وبتجمعهم صداقه وعلاقه قويه جدا في
الواقع ومن وقت ما تاهلوا عرفوا انهم هم
راحوا يواجهوا بعض كانت التعليقات على هذا
الموضوع شغاله وحتى راح اشرف مزح كيلين
على تويتر وقال له نلتقي قريبا ورد عليه
صديقه اما بعد المباراه فاكلين صديق وعلى
تويتر كمان وكتب له مع صوره لهم لا تحزن
يا صديقي الجميع فخور بما حققت لقد دخلت
التاريخ وحكيم يرد عليه باموجي قلب حب
وسلام بالايدين همم خلونا المشاهدين ان
نتفاهم مع صور متداوله بشكل واسع من
المباراه
90 دقيقه بس امس كانوا
[موسيقى]
بي تي اس وابلاك بينك فرق غنائيه كوريه
مكسحه العالم ومن اشهر يعني خلينا نقول
يعني مثلا انه تفتحين العالم وهم من اهم
الفرق في عالم الكيبوب لكن الان في فرقه
جديده نسبيا في هذا العالم
لتحقيق نفس النجاح والانتشار حول العالم
وبدات نشاطها في 20 21 وهي مكونه من 11
بنت
[موسيقى]
مثل ما شفته في الصور او المقاطع اللي
عرضناها يعني كانها فرقه غنائيه مثل غيرها
لكن المفاجاه الحقيقيه هي هيه اعضاءها
فالفرقه ما هي الا فرقه افتراضيه او
المغنيات اللي شايفينهم هدولي مو حقيقيين
خلقوا عن طريق برمجيه الذكاء اصطناعي
عملتها شركه اسمها
متخصصه في التعلم العميق او الديبورنينج
واللي معنا ببساطه تعليم الكمبيوتر يعمل
البني ادميه او يعمل ايه البني ادمين
يعملوه هذه الشركه قررت تعمل الفرقه وراحت
مستخدم التقنيه الديك اولا وعمله
121 او نموذج استخدموا فيهم صفات عامه
معروفه فيهم نجوم الكيبوب انهم مثلا جدد
ابرياء الاذكياء كيوت وبعدين خلوا
الجمهوري يصوت على الوجوه هذه وجابوا
مصممين وخلوهم يبنوا على الوجوه اللي اخذ
اعلى نسبه الصور والفرقه ده حسابات على
المنصات على الاف او عليها الاف المتابعين
ويعني مثلها مثل الحسابات النجوم بالضبط
واغانيها بتنزل اليوتيوب وعليها ملايين
المشاهدات الاغنيه اللي شايفينها نازله من
شهر بس وعليها السته ونصف مليون مشاهده
يعني فرقه زي اي فرقه ثانيه لها معجبينها
ومتابعينها وكله يعني اما بالنسبه اللي
الغناه في الاصوات اللي سمعتوها هي
الاصوات المغنيين حقيقيين مذاكره اصطناعي
والشركه بيقول انه في الفيديوهات هذه اكثر
تحديدا جزئيه لسه محتاج شغل لانه اكثر شيء
لو ركز فيه المشاهدات هينتبه انه الفم مو
ماشي مع الغنى بالضبط ليش الشركه عملت
فرقه افتراضيه بتقول لي لانها شايف انه
هذا المستقبل الكيبوب والفن عموما وللعلمي
انا وهي حتى انه كل واحده من اعضاء الفريق
تعمل لهم منه اصوله يعني ما صار منفرد كده
ويصير وينزلوا سنجلز يعني الفرق البني
ادمين موجودين عليهم الطبيعيين يعني هذا
غير شويه شغل لهم طبعا كمان في الاعلانات
وعلى السوشل ميديا كمان مفاجاه ثانيه
اكتشفناها كمان انه هذه مو اول فرقه كوريه
فيها اعضاء افاتارز ففي فرقه ثانيه اسمها
اسبا وهذه اعضائها اربع بني ادمين واربع
افاتارز
شفا عمر 25 سؤال لازم جواب عليهم
في بلدك سوريا
همم هلا هذا طبعا اكيد بي- يعني بيعطيني
شعور بالضغط بخصوص هذا الموضوع لكن انا
بالنهايه طباخ فقط يعني هذا الشيء شخصي
هذا شيء انا حرفي يعني شخصي بالنسبه لي
اوكي مين اشطر في الطبخه انت او زوجتك
الاحراج ده لا انا طبعا
باعتراف هي طبعا اوكي اصعب تجربه مريت بها
كلاج
انا الصراحه ما مريت باي موقف له علاقه
مثلا بشيء من العنصريه او هذه المواضيع
ابدا او توجه لي كلام من حدا الحمد لله
لحد الان ابدا طيب لما بتخفي ليش بتخفي
زوجتك وما بتظهرها معك هذا الموضوع
[موسيقى]
هي حره فيه يعني
انا ما عندي مشكله حاب تطلع تطلع بس هي ما
بدك
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
بعد عشر سنوات من الان عامل معك لقاء ثاني
غير هذا كمان 25 سؤال
ان شاء الله ان شاء الله
لا دائما ببلاش المفروض تطولت محجوزه
المفروض يعني طيب مين اكثر شاف بيلفتك
محتواه وبيتابعه على يوتيوب
متى سيعود الشيف عمر من تركيا ويستقر في
العالم العربي
قريبا قريبا جدا
ثلاثه ملايين بتفوق الربع مليون دولار
سنويا بطل دور عليهم ما يكفروا مليون مره
صحيح هذا الكلام غلط
[موسيقى]
يعني 200 ايي 240 مثلا 23
[ضحك]
اكله انت فاشل فيها
الصراحه
اكثر جمله اشتهرت فيها
الله
الرجال دائما
ايه طبعا يعني الحقيقه
النساء ممكن عندهم صبر الاكل بده صبر يعني
غير المحبه وغير كثير شغلات بده صبر اكيد
اكل امهات
يعني
الصبر انا عم بحكي عن موضوع الصبر
كان مكتوب عليها انه اسم زي اسم يعني
انا اذا بعدها بلدي ما حدا قال له عندي
يعني الوقت بدي ارجع على بلدي برجع بالوقت
لي انا بدي اياه وما حدا بيمنعني طبعا طيب
فقد كثير من وزنك ايش السر
من بعد ما طلعت من كيتو دايت لحد الان
ثلاث سنين ممنوع سكره ابيض الا طبعا
بالتصوير هيك اما بس شاي والقهوه والسفر
طيب شخصيه
شهيرهم عندك في المطبخ
[موسيقى]
همم ايمن رضا استاذ ايمن رضا
انا مثله طبعا يعني
وكثير بحبه تواصل انا واياه على طول نحكي
تليفونات مع بعض وهو متابعني وانا طبعا
اكيد يعني متابعه وفي فكره يعني يوم من
الايام اكيد نعمل شيء مع بعض طيب اوصف
بنتك لونا وبنتك في كلمه
الخوف الكاميرا
جديده في المطبخ العربي ومن هنا بدات
تغيير ما تحس انك بلغت في وصف نفسك يعني
وتاثيرك كشف
هون في نقطه في انسان مثلا انه عم يعمل
شيء كثير كبير من حاله انه انا هيك وانا
هيك لا انا ما اقصد بيهي الجمله بالضبط
همم شايف عمر هو اول مين دخل همم النكته
والمسحه لقلب الاكل قبل ما كانت موجوده
يعني اي حدا بتشوفيني اليوم عم يمزح وعم
بيساوي اكل هذا بعد
التلفزيون
يعني مثلا حسن او عفوا حسين الامام لما
كان بيطلع مع عمرو اديب وبيطبخ كان دائما
بينكت وبيعلق عمرو اديب هو اللي كان يمزح
وحتى حسين
بيشوفوا انه سيف ذو حدين بيخاف بقول لك
انه انا عم بشتغل بالاكل وامزح الموضوع
مرعب مع انه ممكن يكون شخصيه جدا على
الواقع لكن بيشوف الموضوع بخوف بالنسبه له
انا اساسا لما طلعت من الاصطناع لما تحولت
يعني خلص انه رجعت على طبيعتي بدي اعمل
الكاميرا يوتيوب
يوتيوب
منصات السوشيال ميديا بشكل عام
واحد من الانتقادات ضدك انك تحكي كثير في
فيديوهاتك انا ما بحكي كثير اليوم في عندك
كم هائل من المعلومات انا دائما بحط حالي
محل الانسان اللي عم بيتفرج علي بده ياخذ
الوصفه في امور بسيطه الشيف يعني باقي
شايفين
الكشاف انا بسيطه لكن الناس اللي بتتفرج
ما بتعرف لازم اشرح كلها بفيديو ما يكون
طويل وما يكون ممل بشكل سريع جدا فانا
مضطر احكي بهذا الشكل انا بالفيديو ما
بحكي بسرعه لكن لما بيصير في مونتاج وقطع
الكلام كله متوصل مع بعضه بالعكس الناس
يعني انا لازم بالنهائي وصل المعلومه
الناس
مسلسل سوري
امم اوكي بس ما انت معارض فكره التمثيل
اذا شيء ذوقيني
مسلسل بقدم ايمي للمجتمع طيب من واحد
لعشره قديش انت عصبي
اكثر طلب بيطلبوه منك متابعينك
[ضحك]
طيب اهم ففي الشافه الناجح
يكون متواضع
كشف اصدقاء
[موسيقى]
يعني يكون في علم وراء هذا الشيء اللي عم
يشتغل ويكون في عنده نفس ومحبه بتشيل عم
بيعملوا هذول الشغلتين لازم يجمعون انا
فكرتها بتحاكيني
كسوشيري يعني ترك امه وترك اهله
بعد بعد المليون ولا بعد 100 مليون
طبعا اكيد